ci sono storie che non vengono mai
raccontate storie talmente agghiaccianti
che rimangono sepolte nel tempo quello
che sto per raccontarvi oggi è qualcosa
di ma che cazzo stai facendo cretino
piccoli brividi
la serie di libri che ha segnato
l'intera generazione degli anni 90 tra i
più pazzi vga i giovani le videocassette
della disney ogni bambino della mia
scuola aveva almeno uno di questi
romanzi in casa e tra l'altro ci
scambiavamo come figurine
ammettiamolo decidevamo quali comprare
solo ed esclusivamente in base alla
bellezza della copertina ma prima o poi
te ne ritrovati a decine di centinaia
sparpagliati in casa questo perché
costavano poco si erano veloci da
leggere si facevano paura e non proprio
perone storie erano sempre affascinanti
e lo sono tuttora la cosa che
personalmente mi faceva impazzire erano
questi finali alla m.night shyamalan che
spesso cambiavano l'intero senso del
racconto e ancora oggi nei mercatini
dell'usato polverosi che ti viene
l'epatite solo a guardarli quando ne
trovò uno che mi manca lo prendo
pochissimi euro con tutto quel successo
a un certo punto alcuni produttori hanno
pensato a casa e decorata la serie
televisiva di piccoli brividi
mentre ora quando esce la notizia di una
possibile trasposizione cinematografica
di qualche libro il culo dei lettori di
tutto il mondo si stringe sperando che
non rovinino tutto
prima invece erano tutti contenti e
sederi in tv o al cinema qualcosa che ti
piaceva leggere tagliate mila gola che
questo è il paradiso amavo ogni singola
puntata di ogni singola stagione più o
meno e non solo altri seri come hai
paura del buio al più recente the
hunting hour anno
molto molto valide ma purtroppo non
tutte le puntate escono col buco
questo libro qua l'attacco del mutante
era uno dei miei preferiti
che cazzo fatto qua ma come si toglie
sti cazzo di adesivi macura lasciato una
storia incentrata sui superiori dei
fumetti non può non attirare gli
spettatori soprattutto quelli più
giovani fondo i fumetti per te erano
solo sono il salvatore del mondo
chi ha invece la voglia distruggere
vittoria invece l'episodio di appunto
l'attacco del mutante e parecchio strano
i dialoghi i personaggi e gli scenari
sono tutti i fottuti oltre due anni fa
feci un video simile a questo quando
ancora il mondo era giallognolo ma
venuto solo per violazione di copyright
allora mi dici ok lasciamo perdere
qualche mese fa per uno youtuber
americano che segua fatto una cosa
simile senza conseguenze allora
riproviamoci questo è l'attacco del
mutante
tenete a mente che io possiedo i dvd
originali in inglese mentre la puntata
in italiano dovuta prendere in prestito
da frisbee la puntata inizia con il
nostro protagonista che legge un fumetto
dopo essersi iniettato la fiala di
adrenalina nel cuore l'eternita
[Risate]
ma il ballo la prova questo cigno
d'argento vedi e una prima edizione lo
sai quanto può valere quanto signore non
è questo il punto la tua ossessione fra
queste porcherie
come dire malsana a ci siamo passati
tutti far capire i genitori che le
nostre passioni non solo solo una
perdita di tempo
buona fortuna a fratello devi credermi
tutta quella robaccia finirà per rovina
o co almaty genitori [ __ ] dal
1990 intanto il fumetto si gonfia tipo
bambola gonfiabile
non ci volete portare a scuola le cose
per skipper non vanno meglio anche
l'amico wilson sembra non avere nulla in
comune con lui guarda e che cos'ha di
speciale se lo tieni in questo modo
sembra una meta sioux insomma è proprio
un'altra quella fu una caramellina atti
una caramellina dal ma perché fai
collezione di sassi non lo so è facile
trovarli in qualunque posto striato
sempre un sasso nei paraggi che
coincidenza anche io per lo stesso
identico motivo colleziono palline di
schifo che gli ombelichi mentre una
nuova ogni giorno e poi la frase del
secolo
io non capisco cacciati tanto bello in
cui fumetto manda legittima detta da uno
che colleziona roccia a forma di ad anna
trap che stupidi fumetti guarda che mela
la mia fattoria sul pullman tornando a
casa fa la conoscenza di lippi una
ragazzina che va nella sua stessa scuola
o o o o lo straw skipper ho fatto colpo
che i ragazzi della practice sono tutti
come te no io sono il più grande su
femmine
[Applauso]
ma per una distrazione scende alla
fermata sbagliata e vede un qualcosa
uscito direttamente dai suoi fumetti
[Musica]
il rifugio del mutante
e impossibile
e sempre bello quando un rifugio segreto
assomiglia al pelle di barmen a casa
però continua la discriminazione
razziale
[Musica]
peccato è pagina non stabile gente
fumetti poveraccia costretta a
nascondere i fumetti nei traumi viaggi
bra per paura delle mazzate dei genitori
guarda che chiamò il telefono azzurro lo
faccio ma che poi è ironico che il padre
o di fumetti quando assomiglia
incredibilmente a clark kent ma ok
skipper quindi riprenderà autobus per
tornare al rifugio ma ovviamente è
sparito era uguale a questo è il
perfetto soffre di allucinazioni questa
ron athey rovinerà il cervello ma che
cazzo amo le persone sta cita lo
trattano come se fosse uno psicopatico
che leggi porno in pubblico io mi
scandalizzerei di più per i genitori che
l'hanno chiamato skipper o che rompono
le palle per due fumetti quando la madre
fine g romanzi rosa per zitelle
[Musica]
siamo ad entrare nel nuovo numero del
mutante mascherato si parla di una
cortina invisibile che circonda rifugio
ha creato una cortina invisibile attorno
al mio rifugio segreto quindi insieme
alibi confermano la teoria ed entrano o
no sono gli scarti delle scenografie di
teletubbies in un posto bellissimo a
poco prima skipper viene colpito da un
flash
tenete una mente per il finale dopo aver
preso un ascensore d'aver perso di vista
alibi ovviamente trova una stanza piena
di disegni sì se fossi nato nella corea
del sud
non ti somiglia mai nella vita proprio
ma vergognati nome verrai a dire che hai
paura di una figura di cartone cosa o
only be sì veramente una [ __ ]
ma devo scappare presto tornando a casa
iniziano i problemi
cosa uno psicologo infantile era
convinto che certi ragazzi sono talmente
suggestionati degli metti che vivono in
un loro mondo fantastico e non è quello
che ho sempre detto ma sei sicuro che
non vuoi anche tu una caramellina
guardate ma avanzano va bene vai a
parlare col tuo amico va che magari ti
aiuta magari sta impazzendo
no mi sbagliavo di grosso se il suo
migliore amico ma dagli supporto morale
non riesco più a riconoscere la realtà è
successo a me aziona all'inizio ha
cominciato a vedere cose che non
esistevano poi ho iniziato a sentire
degli odori
alla fine lo hanno ricoverato se il
udine come le toux stupide roccia wilson
vergogna nel nuovo numero del mutante
cisco perché anche la sua controparte
asiatica e nella storia così finalmente
alle prove da far vedere i genitori ci
sono anche io e questo buio nei doveri
dentro per papa devi dare un'occhiata
con i ma proprio in quel momento il
padre accecato dalle cipolle e la madre
prepara il caffè mentre legge e quindi
non lo caga nessuno e togli di qualcosa
da sotto il naso nel cipolle mi fanno
piangere so che c'è un trucco per non
piangere
però non ho idea di quale sia
no no ho bisogno di stare lassù anche un
attimo
quindi nel bel mezzo della notte
complimenti i genitori torna al rifugio
e come se non bastasse si becca un altro
avvertimento
mi piace ai fumetti
bisogna stare attenti nei piatti la
mente
oh mio dio l'avremo giudicato meno se
avesse accoltellato qualcuno quel
fumetto
lo sai che anche hitler leggeri fumetti
non vorrà rifare la sua stessa fine
ci stiamo avvicinando al finale però
quale sarà il mistero che nasconde il
nascondiglio skipper entra nei
sotterranei e trova il super eroe
protagonista di fumetti legato ad una
sedia sei una gazzella tano pan
chiedo scusa come se la gazzella
talebani eh sì hanno mandato lui perché
il frigorifero refrigerante non poteva
con me ma la cosa più buffa di tutto
questo è che l'attore che interpreta la
gazzella galoppante e adam west
non sto scherzando è veramente lui è uno
dei temi che dobbiamo sbrigarci i pieni
di questo re dei quiz sono come i
carciofi dopo averlo liberato trovano la
postazione del mutante gazzella si siede
sulla sedia ma colpo di scena il mutante
è la sedia
cacciari serventi e grazie per gli
incubi perché il suo potere e
trasformarsi in qualsiasi cosa
mentre il potere dello strano e
aspettano vorrei eroe ha ragione lui
sono troppo vecchio per fare il
supereroe è il tuo turno ragazzo è sotto
[Musica]
tagliare la corda che hanno già mandato
a cagare da o se non lo faccio io è il
plot visto il numero due
lippi non è mai esistita è sempre stato
il mutante trasformato era niente a
nessuno sul serio non posso lasciarti
andare cantanta che poi devono spiegarci
perché vogliono catturare i bambini di
10 anni ma cantanta colpo di scena
numero 3 viene spiegato il raggio di
luce all'inizio era un analizzatore e
quando ci sei passato dentro analizzato
tutte ora sei un personaggio dei fumetti
proprio bene che i ma perché chi piano
di conquista del mondo e trasformare le
persone i personaggi di un fumetto se
poi vuole ucciderli e come son fatti che
volesse conquistare il mondo
trasformando tutti in budget e poi se
l'è magna è poi tutto si fotte
seguitemi skipper finge di essere un
supereroe elastic boy e io sono al mente
quella scavare e finge di dirgli il suo
finto punto debole sui l'acido in modo
da far trasformare il mutante in un
liquido c'è solamente un modo per
distruggere la streep poi con l'acido
solforico mai dimenticato una cosa a se
ti trasformi in un solido torni normale
ma se ti trasformi in un liquido sei
morto il grande tante mascherato battuto
il mutante è morto perché si dimenticato
che se si trasforma in un liquido muore
miglior superiore della vita ma
aspettate che c'è ancora un ultimo super
colpo di schiena
[Musica]
sono confuso ma prima quindi non aveva
fatto finta era davvero elastico quindi
si è trasformato davvero con quella luce
lì è perché è vestito come un amaretto
ubriaca non lo so ma è finito questo era
dove lo staff questo era l'attacco del
mutante uno di molti episodi che mi sono
rimasti in mente per anni magari il
passare di tutti questi anni non aiuta
all'invecchiamento ma di sicuro aiuta ad
aumentare lo charme ora scusate devo
andare a leggere i fumetti in cantina
altri eletti mischiavano
[Musica]